ce sont vous avez été incroyablement ça
fait kiffer amant
la météo
on a eu l'idée de lancer notre label
entendait et va s'appeler apache musique
maintenant faut comprendre faire est ce
que vous êtes déjà à chaussures des
artistes on cherche nos premières
signatures
timmins et neuf meilleurs qu'à majorité
nomique encore
quels sont les réseaux sous qui était
repris par les plus gros contrat
français 1-0 quoi ça va pas du tout j'ai
pas envie de raconter ma vie mais c'est
pas pour rien que j'arrêtais nous y
compris moi sinon je veux nique et
apache musique
j'ai besoin d'être pour ça
brême ne remet pas dans les ombres ont
pas besoin et ouvre les yeux on est déjà
dans les embrouilles germond a sûrement
là
[Musique]